We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Launch control. This is Space Venture. Radio is on Roger.
我们得到加州大学戴维斯分校的支持。这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这全是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。发射控制。这里是太空风暴。电台已连接，收到。
Spacecraft design is a study in humanity. At least that's what Mary Roach says. My name is Mary Roach. I'm the author of Packing for Mars, the curious science of life and the void. In the beginning, the designers of the space habitation modules. The box where the crew lives. Yep, that's the one. They stuck with what they knew.
航天器设计是对人性的研究。玛丽·罗奇也是这么说的。我叫玛丽·罗奇。我是《火星打包：太空生存的奇妙科学》一书的作者。起初，太空居住舱的设计师们，也就是乘员居住的那个盒子——是的，就是那个——他们沿用了他们熟悉的东西。
Very few people had spent any time up there or in zero gravity. People had just intuitively designed it like a room on earth. There would be control panel and then there were little chairs. There were seats that you would sit and it makes no sense. In zero gravity you can't sit. You would have to strap yourself to the seat. The reason is simple. We are humans. When we have a room we have a floor and a ceiling we have chairs and tables and that's what we do and that's how it was designed. But getting stuff into space is expensive. So there's always a grand effort to minimize
很少有人在太空或零重力环境下呆过。人们凭直觉把它设计得就像地球上的一个房间。会有一个控制面板，然后有一些小椅子。有供你坐的座位，但这毫无意义。在零重力下你不能坐。你必须把自己绑在座位上。原因很简单。我们是人类。当我们有一个房间时，我们有地板和天花板，我们有椅子和桌子，这就是我们的做法，也是它的设计方式。但是把东西送入太空是很昂贵的。因此，人们总是付出巨大的努力来尽量减少
weight and to create the most efficient space possible. And all those human comforts came under scrutiny. So then they went through the other extreme, get rid of it all, because in space, the walls become your table. If you have a table and you put something down on the table, the table doesn't act like a table. It doesn't hold it. It just floats off.
重量并创造最有效的空间。所有这些人类的舒适感都受到了严格的审查。于是他们走向了另一个极端，把它们统统扔掉，因为在太空中，墙壁就成了你的桌子。如果你有一张桌子，你把东西放在桌子上，桌子就不会像桌子那样起作用。它不会托住它。它只会漂浮开来。
A drawer isn't very good. You open the door, everything flies out. So what you have is pieces of elastic on the wall Like, you know, you pull the elastic back and you stick your clipboard in there and everything has bits of velcro So the walls become the tables. You have a very bare Box that you're living in. So that became the game plan no furniture no ceiling no floor a perfect utilitarian box Or the astronaut floats freely and uses every surface to the fullest.
抽屉不是很好用。你打开门，所有的东西都会飞出来。所以你拥有的是墙上的弹性带，你知道，你拉回弹性带，然后把你的写字板塞进去，每样东西都有魔术贴的碎片，所以墙壁变成了桌子。你生活在一个非常光秃秃的盒子里。所以这就成了游戏计划：没有家具，没有天花板，没有地板，一个完美的实用盒子。宇航员在其中自由漂浮，并充分利用每一个表面。
The great thing about zero gravity, we can use the ceiling, we could put the bathroom on the wall. But this is where the human factor comes in. The capsule became over-designed for the 0G condition, and it became too alien. The humanity was lost. The one thing that the crews decided that they were not okay
零重力最棒的地方在于，我们可以使用天花板，我们可以把浴室放在墙上。但这就是人为因素发挥作用的地方。太空舱针对零重力条件进行了过度设计，变得过于陌生。人性迷失了。乘员们认为绝对不能妥协的一件事
was getting rid of a kitchen table, like a dining table, a place to gather around at the end of the day, you don't know, sit down or pretend to sit down, and talk about what you did over the day, eat, shami were humans. Human beings want to sit around the table and gossip and talk about stuff and eat and drink.
就是扔掉厨房的桌子，比如餐桌，一个在一天结束时可以聚在一起的地方，你不知道，坐下来或者假装坐下来，聊聊你这一天做了什么，吃饭，因为我们是人类。人类想要围坐在桌子旁八卦、聊聊天、吃吃喝喝。
And the table came back. It's a small table and there's little pieces of elastic and velcro and they all hover around the table. So despite that horrifying scene of alien, a table on a spacecraft makes for a happy astronaut. So in the living quarters, there's now an effort to use Earth orientation. The bottom part is the floor and ceiling above, walls or walls. The way that they cue them in is like the lighting will be up above.
桌子又回来了。这是一张小桌子，上面有小块的松紧带和魔术贴，他们都盘旋在桌子周围。因此，尽管外星飞船的场景令人毛骨悚然，但航天器上有一张桌子能让宇航员感到快乐。所以在生活区，现在人们努力使用地球方向。底部是地板，上方是天花板，墙壁就是墙壁。他们提示他们的方式就像照明会在上方一样。
So there's always ways so that you know what the accepted orientation is. Keeping one orientation helps in the constant war against motion sickness. And having everyone in the same orientation also helps the crew talk with one another. I interviewed this astronaut Lee Moran about how troubling it is to try to have a conversation
因此总有方法让你知道被接受的方向是什么。保持一个方向有助于持续对抗晕动症。让每个人都朝着同一个方向也有助于机组成员相互交谈。我采访了一位名叫李·莫兰的宇航员，谈到了尝试进行对话是多么令人烦恼
with somebody who is upside down when you were right-side up. We're sort of lip-reading all the time without realizing it. And he said, when you go beyond a 45-degree angle, the other person starts to have trouble reading your lips. So it's considered in polite to carry on a conversation with someone when you are upside down or when you are differently oriented. I love these examples and the fundamentals of other worldly space design because if you were to recreate that exercise right here in the gravity-based habitat and start from scratch, what would you redesign completely? Would everything simply evolve back to the way it is now?
当你正立时，和一个倒立的人在一起。我们一直在下意识地进行唇语阅读。他说，当你超过 45 度角时，对方就开始很难看懂你的唇语。因此，当你倒立或方向不同时，与他人继续谈话被认为是无礼的。我喜欢这些例子以及其他世界太空设计的基础知识，因为如果你要在基于重力的栖息地中重现这一练习并从头开始，你会完全重新设计什么？一切都会简单地演变回现在的样子吗？
Would US currency still be inexplicably uniform in color and size? Could we get rid of cars if we started over? Could we finally make the steam punkers happy and have a sky full of derogables? My guess is that even the poorly designed and inefficient objects would make come back, because it might just be your dining room table, your crappy, wobbly, a square-honey I will fix it soon, I promise it might be that dining room table that makes you happy astronaut. 99% Invisible is produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar.
美国货币在颜色和大小上是否仍然莫名其妙地统一？如果我们重新开始，我们能摆脱汽车吗？我们能最终让蒸汽朋克迷高兴并拥有一片布满飞艇的天空吗？我猜，即使是设计糟糕、效率低下的物体也会卷土重来，因为那可能只是你的餐桌，你那破烂的、摇晃的、方方正正的宝贝，我很快就会修好它，我保证，那可能就是让你这个宇航员快乐的餐桌。“99%隐形”由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持。
It's a project of KLW, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco in the center for architecture and design. Find out more at 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是 KLW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的项目。请访问 99%invisible.org 了解更多信息。该剧集尚无评论。点击成绩单中的任意句子即可留下评论。